tell me everything cuz this is like the
first we're learning a free guy we're
like learning what it's about I know
it's so rare that a movie is gonna come
out that we don't know everything about
in advance but today was really about
giving New York comic-con the lowdown on
the movie a glimpse of this incredible
cast and a little sneak peek at a bunch
of footage
I heard you you revealed some of the
cameos that are gonna be in yeah well
the movie is very much kind of set in
the world of video games and gaming
culture so in order to have a kind of
authenticity to that I reach out to
ninja I reached out to pokey main a few
others like laser beam jacksepticeye
names that everyone over 40 does not
know names that I did not know 18 months
ago but who are you know kind of very
much the voice of this gaming culture
certainly celebrities in that culture
and if we're making a movie about that
world we need authenticity to that world
sure now I also heard that you were
gonna cameo yourself but then what
happens to here but yes I played a nut
vendor and I had a hat and an apron
that's advertised hot nuts and I
literally had a cart hot nuts get your
hot nuts but I couldn't bear to watch my
own acting so I've already cut myself
out of the movie so the world is robbed
of that delicious opportunity darn nice
to wear my hot nuts cap like on date
night at home you got - sure sure my
wife loves it don't let it go she hasn't
said she loves it I can tell she okay
before I let you go we just got a teaser
for stranger things season 4 yeah yeah
you know that I can't say much on that
topic but between that sentence and
maybe a few other Easter eggs in the
thing we released maybe you know more
than you think
dig into that I'm serious I know I
change her things has taught me anything
it's how to speak while saying nothing
and come off super cagey I am an apse
well yeah we just dropped something and
then walk away yeah exactly exactly but
I mean are stranger things fans are the
best fans I've seen in my life and and
we're excited to get to work on season
four
let's talk to you